Nó, việc chi sốt gồn góp được á dụng mắt buộc lối với khách sản pầm, hàng ngoáng mất nụ dụng giủ gió cao, thuộc phòng vi quản lý của bộ công ty hoàn,
quy định này giằm tăng cường khả năng kiểm sốt gồn gốc hàng ngoá bảo về quyết lời người tư dụng giống cho phát triển lợi trọn và sự dụng sản pầm.
Để chìa, khai quy định mới, bộ công thường bận hành tập trung hệ thống chi sốt gồn gốc hàng ngoá tại để chi,
và đi gút cho viêng, nấy lo này tăng tiếp dật lưu trữ khoảng lý và kết nối giữ liệu chi sốt gồn gốc sản pầm.
Hành ngoá sốt xuân nghiệp cập giật, lúc thời tạo lập mả thuộc buộc việc chiến thị, chà tụi và chi sẻ giữ liệu,
mắt nầu được kích cứu xây dựng và bệnh hành được gối thống bệ 2, nằm hình luật 2 vi làm.
Đến hết thẳng năm, nằm hình cũng trọng hệ bị sấu, hệ tổ chí sốt gồn gốc hàng ngoá về rế gút đã sắc thực hơn một chiệu mạ sản pầm.
Kết quản này, cho thế hệ thống đã tưởng nước hình thành cơ sở giữ liệu phục vụ phạt động truy sất bồn gốc,
tạo nên tàng cho việc chiến thay đồng vụ các quy định mới từ ngày 1,5 bệnh ám mạnh hiện 1 trọng hệ bị sấu.
Thúc qua hệ thống, liệu tư dụng giống có thể chắc khi uống biển phi các thông tin cơ bản của sản pầm.
Hành ngoá như thế sản pầm, khi ngành lất vì sản xuất hoặc việc giói, để chiến xuất nghiệp thương hiệu, gián hiệu, số lâu sản xuất, số xe ri và hản xuất lựa có.
Không chỉ dừng lại ở việc chắc kỹ thuộc thông tin, người thương dùng còn gói, quyền phản nãnh tử ý bộ công thường, phật sơ quan có thầm quyền.
Hãy phát hiện thông tin, vình tì hệ thống không chỉ xác, và có giống hiệu không chung thực, khá quy định của pháp lợt, với bảo vệ quyền lời người thương dùng.